"Легке життя закінчилося" -
так коментують абсолютну перемогу партії "Слуга народу"
на парламентських виборах в Україні німецькі ЗМІ.
Дотепер парламент блокував ініціативи Володимира Зеленського.
Нині ж президент має виправдати довіру українців,
які втомилися від старих еліт й обрали політиків-новачків,
та втілити очікувані реформи.
На вирішення усіх цих питань сподіваються не лише українські виборці,
але і партнери Києва у Берліні та Брюсселі.
Результати виборів в Європі називають не лише очікуваними,
але й історичними, адже вперше за роки незалежності в Україні
одній партії може вдатися здобути абсолютну більшість у парламенті.
Проблеми у цьому на Заході не бачать.
Абсолютна більшість несе небезпеку зловживання,
але вона ж дає і велетенські шанси.
За нинішньої ситуації в Україні тут більше шансів, аніж ризиків.
Втім, успіх партії Зеленського на виборах - це не лише шанс
на повну реалізацію його політичної програми,
застерігають оглядачі, але і відповідальність перед українцями.
Буде менше можливостей звинувачувати інших політиків у невдачах.
Попри нижчу, ніж на попередніх виборах, явку
багато людей покладають сподівання на нову партію.
Очевидно, що якщо ця партія, новий уряд не дадуть результату,
це призведе до подальшого розчарування та розділення суспільства.
Вибори до Ради важливі не лише для України, але й
можуть мати ризики міжнародного масштабу,
застерігають оглядачі видання Die Welt:
Через те, що Росія веде в Україні війну, партія "Слуга народу"
нині в ситуації, в якій не перебуває жодна інша
протестна партія Європи, пише видання.
Це й робить результати виборів такими важливими для європейців.